et maintenant mesdames messieurs
ce tirage
vous connaissiez vous que tout le monde
connait rails je sais pas moi je vous
connais en tout les cas vous appelez pas
vraiment rails en plus de flairer mundo
souza dira de oliveira dire aïe un plus
facile juste le frère de socrate est
quand même une sacrée famille un
international de l'équipe du brésil à 22
ans rapidement capitaine de la seleçao
65 sélections 30 buts meilleur joueur
sud américain en 92 et en 93 vous
débarquer au psg où vous retrouvez vos
copains valdo et ricardo et vous partiez
du psg quelques années plus tard en 97
après un joli doublé la coupe de france
et la coupe de la ligue
vous rentrez en 95 à sao paulo et vous
achetez votre carrière de footballeur
pro en juillet 2000 et l'a récemment se
jouer un dernier match un match amical
contre flamengo en janvier 2001 donc
juste pour votre fondation en fait non
on n'a pas fait les c'est un match
jubilé ouais quand on doit faire la mois
de juillet peut-être que peut-être même
avec la varoise et et on va les faire
marcher jubilait si à paris on est en
train de discuter ça avant mais
peut-être au mois de septembre
il faut ce fait toutes les recettes ce
sera paul à pour la fondation la
fondation qu'on a ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que rails après cette magnifique
carrière donc d'abord dans l'équipe du
brésil et ensuite au psg
vous avez créé une fondation qui
s'appelle gol de letra que vous avez
initié vous et financé vous avec votre
ami leonardo 1
alors on va parler un petit peu de la
réalisation de cette fondation il ya ait
fait ça en août 99 ça commence et c'est
sur une colline à côté de sao paulo qui
s'appelle très membe on appelle ça la
colline des poux et la base 50 % des
adolescents ont moins de 4 ans d'école
derrière eux exactement clt me lydienne
surtout sont ces genres d enfants qui
habitent dans les banlieues défavorisées
dont qui avance et qui on essaie de les
apporter
c'est pas né
net comme ça c'est le seul à porter
c'est qu'ils ont le droit de dire des
opportunités une bonne éducation bonheur
des options pour faire des activités
pour pour qu'ils connaissent plein de
choses d'informatique de ça pour qu'il
puisse céder voyez tout seul après oui
en fait c'est pas pour en faire des
footballeur parce que vous vous luttez
beaucoup contre le mythe du football
parce que vous dites que finalement il
ya 1 % des jeunes brésiliens qui
deviennent des stars du football et ça
fait 99 % de de gens qui sont déçus
ouais c'est vrai que surtout dans cette
classe la plus défavorisée et il voit le
[ __ ] comme une façon d des sorciers et
il ya peu de gens qui arrivent dans kiss
on essaie d ne croit à leur portée celle
d'une façon como êtres humains de
citoyens et comme ça il peut s'en sortir
de plusieurs façons différentes
alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est que ça
des résultats parce que dans le centre
là qu'il a créé et le taux de
redoublement est de 5% alors que dans le
reste du brésil il est de 40 %
c'est vrai qu'au brésil n'y a pas une
grande solidarité entre les classes
sociales ah ouais ça n'avait pas mais ça
commence on allait plus en plus de la
société civile commence à bouger un peu
ouais mais c'est un des parce que c'est
un pays riche quand même econocom ans et
c'était le 7e là c'est le huitième
économie du monde
mais c'est un des pires des grandes
paroles de partage de ces stages est
très mal chez à l'injustice sociale très
importante donc il ya des moyens qui on
puisse faire un pays plus juste
donc ça s'appelle gol de letra et est ce
que vous allez faire d'autre d'autres
centres au brésil et dans le monde
ouais à là où on va commencer en
deuxième l'art mois de juillet à rio
ouais c'est où est né
et leonardo ont comme au caire qui avec
moi et on va faire un deuxième et après
pendant deux trois ans on va voir une
expérience qui ont vos après créé et
utilisé des mots des méthodes de
l'éducation que voilà prêts passés à
d'autres sites ou de suisse en eau même
au faire des échanges avec les écoles
publiques
alors vous venez d'une famille très
étonnante votre père autodidacte s'est
plongé dans la philosophie grecque et
alors les enfants de la famille
s'appelle socrates fameux footballeur
évidemment sophocle ce stand et et vous
si votre mère était pas intervenue vous
seriez appelé platon donc il est
intervenu alors enfant vous rêviez pas
du tout d'une carrière de footballeur
non vous aviez votre idole des jeunes et
a dîné tous les jours était à côté de
moi j'étais fier de lui mais je pensais
pas être être très jeune brésilien kaka
mais le foot mais ça pas être pro
c'était une chose qui était
naturellement au gtl c'est tout
naturellement pas tellement ri c'est à
dire que en fait un jour votre amie
christina s'est retrouvée enceinte
wales activement quand son cas serait
pas le joueur alors mais malgré tout
pendant votre carrière vous disait
toujours je vais reprendre mes études je
vais reprendre mes études quand j'aurai
fini ma carrière de footballeur
et c'est ce que vous avez fait
d'ailleurs dès que vous avez eu un peu
de temps vous avez recommencé
réapprendre à vous intégrer à la
philosophie samassa mais ça m'a manqué
il serait un peu l'histoire de ma
famille sont bien alors dit marié à 17
ans avec cristina donc et vous êtes
toujours ensemble non non non plus on a
passé des espoirs je suis persuadé vous
étiez toujours ensemble normal en temps
non mais on s'entend très bien on a
passé 16 ans ensemble
on n'est plus ensemble depuis deux ans
mais en sentant toujours très bien et
j'ai je constate
et aussi parce que c'est pas facile
quand tu commences à 17 ans elle avait
13 ans oui on a passé quand même 16
ensemble c'était je vais vous dire quand
vous êtes venu à paris au psg
elle a très mal pris la vie en français
ça lui plaisait pas du tout la vie en
france et quand vous rendriez à croissy
le soir chez vous elle pleurait elle
était triste et votre couple a survécu à
ce passage difficile en france et ça
s'est arrêté après une fois que vous
êtes retourné au brésil
ouais mais ça n'a pas duré longtemps le
premier 6 7 mois parce qu'il surtout à
cause des enfants des les enfants il ya
du temps à s'adapter aux nouveaux si
c'est une façon différence des vivres
mais on avait envie dst de connaître
notre réalité c'est ça qu'on a fait on a
passé cinq ans en france a noté aurait
aussi bon c'est ça après on est au
nombre et c'était après qu'il a passée
alors au brésil j'étais donc une énorme
star donc comme je le dis en 92 meilleur
joueur d'amérique du sud
sex-symbol vous appelez match numéro un
et 1 mètre 90 90 kg enfin bon tout ce
qu'on n'est pas et pourquoi avoir choisi
le psg plutôt chrome ou madrid
en france même si les gens adorent le
foot sont pas faux mais comme en italie
où la pression va bouger les joueurs
n'ont pas le temps de les connaître la
ville ferait la vie est ici en france
les gens les aiment bien donc on a un
bon rapport avec les supporters mais
aussi on a à côté on peut avoir une
autre vie il s'est même en espagne et en
italie
à leur première saison au psg c'était
assez dur pour vous vous marquez pas
beaucoup vous tourner un peu comme ça
vous aurez un peu sur le terrain vous
appelle fantômas avec toi qu'est ce qui
est pas très sympa et en fait ce que si
vous sortiez de 170 matches en deux ans
quatre par semaine vous êtes arrivé au
psg je suis un peu fatigué oui oui
à passer j'ai passé deux ans et demi en
faisant plein match et pendant les
vacances je sois je vais pour l'équipe
nationale
j'ai passé deux ans d'existence avoir
des vacances en arrivant ici
j'arrivais avec les gens attendaient
beaucoup du mois j'étais fatigué je
pouvais pas être à l'auteur qui ont
attrait mais j'ai eu la passion qu'ils
avaient raison climat il y avait les
terrains qui était détrempée les
terrains qui est et qui était dû aux
problèmes comme on l'a dit avec votre
femme qui a des problèmes pour
s'acclimater
ouais ça a commencé en deuxième saison
leur deuxième saison c'est parti vous
avez marqué 12 buts en 20 matches et
vous être devenu une star
assez rapidement curieusement alors
après ouais après ça ça l'est mais
j'étais content paris on en a gagné
plein de bonnes choses avec des
supporters si j'étais content décidé et
aussi parce que souvent où il ya plein d
surtout les sud américains continuent
syfy si le premier n'est parfois il
rentre moi je voulais aussi aussi on a
géré mon séjour ouais bah vous avez
terminé sur la coupe de france coupe de
la ligue
alors on va vous regarder on va pouvoir
non seulement marqué mais aussi pleuré